el incendio forestal cerca del turístico
destino de sanz pp obligó a miles de
personas entre residentes y turistas a
evacuar los bomberos trabajaban junto
con la gendarmería francesa para
controlar las llamas
el presidente macro visitó la zona
afectada el fuego no se ha apagado aún
está bajo control como las imágenes
muestran lo peor fue evitado pero las
próximas horas serán absolutamente
decisivas y continuaremos vigilantes en
los departamentos afectados
las causas de la conflagración que
inició el lunes aún no han sido
determinadas pero el mandatario francés
señaló al cambio climático y es que en
pleno verano del hemisferio norte que
deja temperatura récord los incendios
forestales consumen bosques en varios
países las llamas mantienen en alerta
españa italia en españa un incendio
forestal en la provincia de ávila
destruyó al menos 15.000 hectáreas desde
el 14 de agosto en los últimos días
italia reportó incendios en calabria
sicilia cerdeña y los alrededores de
roma en grecia una segunda ola de
incendios obligó a evacuar a tres
pueblos del sudeste de atenas más de 100
mil hectáreas en quemadas desde finales
de julio en el país que crece la crisis
climática está aquí y nos enseña que
todo debe cambiar desde la orientación
de la economía a nuestra política
nacional en energía desde el
funcionamiento del estado a los hábitos
diarios de los ciudadanos preocupados
por el ambiente
y en turquía más de 180 focos de
incendios destruyeron al menos 160 mil
hectáreas de bosques y cultivos en tan
solo dos semanas